und in diesem fall waren meine
stellt so etwas machen für euch alle das
klappt
weil antonia nicht den ganzen tag schon
ganz vorne unter hoffentlich ganz vorne
vielleicht vier tornados
eingeladen wird auf den rummel dann
unbekannte einer neuen folge laufen und
die geschäfte haben noch nicht auf aber
lauter einflüsse so knusprig und innen
fünf geschenktüten überrascht die ich
nicht genug war durfte ich mir noch eine
erinnerung möglich ganz genauso wie
kombination mit dem leben in dem der tür
mal drüber probiere auch so sein zuerst
haben wir doch ausgemacht wir beide ja
schon mal in einer tv-show auf
schmeckt wie so oft im fußball aber so
zu bekommen der liebe man vom stand hat
also 05 leger absolute 10 von 10 es ist
pferderennen spiel wo man den ball in
eine richtige stärkung hat und es beim
laufen heute ist es eher bummeln und
verlosen darf also wenn ihr so eine
macht sie einmal ein kartoffel tornado
nickelodeon ausprobiert und dieser sport
nach der wilden maus im einer meine
große bunte tüte an leckereien an ihrem
aber ich kann dafür kartoffel tornados
nach meinem dritten versuch netterweise
carus helfern so richtig spaß macht gab
die löcher bekommen muss war so gut dass
wir haben wenn wir es bekommen
passt ja diese weiche kartoffel das ja
ich durfte bogenschießen ich habe das
diese fahrt ist auch mal mehr
die dieselfahrer
rumeln denn wir sind auf dem fünfzigsten
die tonart und kontrolliert eine zehn
kartoffelecken mit ketchup mal
rummel tüte gewinnen wollt mit viel
ist einfach nur bitter ist und ja
klar da geschlafen und wir legen kann
ganz angenehm und dann kannst du sogar
mütze verloren ich habe meine müsste
wir drei runden gespielt haben die erste
wie ip ticket damit können wir hier um
es als erstes kartoffel wedges dieser
mir das ding geschenkt ich könnte hier
frühlingsfest in berlin hier am kurt
freikarten stofftier und gebrannten
so eine richtige kartoffeln das erste
stand aussuchen also hier nochmal danke
natürlich fühlt man sich dabei wie
spritzgebäck
noch eher blassen hammer tragen dass im
elektro wiedersehen bis jetzt ein guter
von zehn kartoffel in seiner besten form
verloren eine mütze ist weg timo hat in
habe ich gewonnen und die anderen zwei
ketten server dient
mandeln dann geht mal auf meinen
stand gürtel natürlich auch der familie
antonia durch einen kleinen mädchen
schumacher damm auf dem festplatz so
eine frage chef darauf aber mir geht es
express zeit sogar mir jetzt schon mal
natürlich sagen dass ich selber gewonnen
instagram account dort habe ich das
anni antonias rummel kind stolz wird
nietzsche also hier noch mal ein kleines
parteichefin geschenkt bekommt so ribery
bei menden sammeln zwar nicht ganz so
mai live darfst du heute
china genommen und einen chili cheese
einen tollen tag bereitet also leute der
die auf dem bild ist sie noch aber wenn
habe aber ich will natürlich auch
tag aber ich brauche noch etwas süßes
mehr ums essen vielleicht traue ich mich
gewinnspiel reingestellt und dort könnt
dankeschön wir haben jetzt hier
bürger doppelt käses einfach doppelt
die beste kombination dosenwerfen
sich davon wohl nie wieder erholen und
muss unbedingt die letzte bulle
sie schon fliegen die iss schon zum
noch 12 sachen auszuprobieren aber lasst
aber das muss auch sein wir wurden mit
ihr auch mitmachen ich war selten auf
tag auf dem rummel ist vorbei antonia
ehrlich zu euch sein es gehört am ende
du
brot das erste mal habe ich kurz vor
klassiker geworden jetzt habe ich hier
besser oder auf dem leicester fleisch
ausprobieren
nächsten mal mehr das gemacht von da hat
dem rummel und konnte so viele sachen
immer noch glück dazu
hat mir noch ihre milch schnitte
hast einfach die bettlerin pommes weil
uns also erst mal rein antonia hat uns
zehn jahren dänemark gegessen und
mitgegeben milch schnitte mit
ausprobieren und es hat so viel spaß
sie mir gefallen die gopro ausland
nichts mehr sicherlich nicht gewinnen
langsam findet man überall auch in
den ganzen tag über herumgeführt und
ich mit einem projektor unbedingt einmal
gemacht als gebürtige hamburgerin war
schokoladenüberzug das ist wohl deren
käse tomaten zwiebeln gegen calla
geflogen
um mit meiner neuen freundin per papier
ihre familie hat viele stände auf diesen
deutschland usa wie karamell oder soll
und dann ist diese geflogen zu der noch
geheimtipp
zu probieren da war eigentlich nicht
ich natürlich als kind oft auf dem
das erste fahrgeschäft war schon mal
ging es dann zu meinem lieblings stand
peñoles und krise suchen also das sind
hamburger dom und dort sind wir einmal
rummel die familien nicht schon am
wegen laktose
so im wein so von
ich bin einfach alle flecken auch wenn
hole harper wollen wir uns ordentlich
ganz gut also leute hier kommen wir zu
meine milch schnitte im park schokolade
mit der wilden maus gefahren und es war
alles lecker sind also ich werde für
vorbereiten der boden wird verlegt und
dort
einem ganz fantastischen viele automaten
der geschmack war tipptopp unschuldigen
eine so traumatische erfahrung es hat
ganz wow hat auch gerne schokolade
drin um natürlich max natürlich schmeckt
einen reinen lehre
und ich haben auf dem weihnachtsmarkt
die sachen werden aufgefüllt mama
richtig ich muss auch eine werbung geben
zweiter zu bieten
antonia du hattest recht das ist extrem
sich einfach angefühlt als ob man
gesehen dass das alle gespielt haben und
runterfällt die ganze zeit und man sagt
nietzsche ist auch schon gekommen wird
in der boulevard auch liebevollen wir
lecker und wir sehen uns wieder bei
damals haben uns irgendwie nicht getraut
denn die zuckerwatte hat ganz klar eine
ware um
wurden danach noch auf bürger eingeladen
er dass man sich mutig seinen ängsten
da hinzugehen deswegen wollen wir jetzt
was verkaufen zu können
so ein schönes riesenrad auf dem rummel
einer nächsten folge laufen und laufen
heute einmal unbedingt ausprobieren da
probieren jetzt durch die bohlen aus
stellen soll und deswegen bin ich
sieben von zehn verdient die hier sind
und weiß aus dem becher youtuber sollte
beziehungsweise
nochmal aufgegangen ja ich finde nicht
ja ganz klare schon in neun von zehn
so eine schnur und mit diesem spiel und
das muss auch einfach sein und ich hatte
letztes jahr habe ich paule für mich
grummeln und
man sein toller beruf wie gut ist 14 19
aber das was sie sein soll perfekt
entdeckt und seitdem bin ich ein großer
freizeitgerät kann man die wer gewinnt
so richtig bock damit zu fahren es ist
bummeln an die fans jetzt nach hause ich
und wir waren darauf auf toilette gehen
fan die auswahl hier war wirklich groß
so herzerwärmend einfach was wir nette
aber ich konnte leider nicht jeder pole
habe keinen bock mehr irgendwas zu tun
zu können wir sind gespannt wir sind
probieren das coolste hier war dass sie
menschen auf diesen rummel arbeiten
bis denne ok
alles so ein bisschen wie kleine kinder
besonders der riesenrad mann war einfach
so eine art weinflasche hatten also
na ich habe an die dabei timo ist eine
werden jetzt und dann machen wir weiter
10 14 das wenn man von antonia
camera link mal timo
gefrorenen wein den sie erstmal rein
punkten
machen und darauf dann die bowle kaiser
probiert erstmal die alkoholfreie da
ich hab' ich habe
und dann habe ich mir einen lebenstraum
erfüllt ich durfte den ansager machen
natürlich einen wagen mit allen
süßigkeiten die man auf so einem rummel
essen möchte schokofrüchte zucker
kandierte früchte mandeln alles was das
herz begehrt ja klar wir wollen immer
nur auf der anderen seite steht und lass
mir form
und natürlich zuckerwatte ich war mega
aufgeregt denn ich durfte das allererste
mal in meinem leben eine richtige
zuckerwatte selber machen und mir wurde
sogar gesagt dass sie für meinen ersten
versuch gar nicht mal so schlecht ist
kommen wir zu dem ersten test meine
selbstgemachte zuckerwatte ich habe sie
schon probiert sogar wartet damit kann
man nichts falsch machen das ist einfach
ein ganz klassischer rummel habe ich als
kind geliebt und lebe ich eigentlich
auch noch heute und damit unser magen so
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]